rail name something that's hard to do
with your eyes open read
[Applause]
something that's hard to do with your
eyes open
this boy in college
something that has to warm up before you
use it sir how about your wife
[Applause]
man of the world traveled all over the
world something Russia is famous for Bob
Russians
foreign
thank you start with s
and another
l and a vowel
you
and a consonant
tea
okay on a magnetic compass which
direction is directly opposite to East
North name something specific of
Leonardo DiCaprio's that you like to
hold the Mona Lisa is painting
yes
name Popeye's favorite food
[Applause]
name something a teenage boy can do for
hours at a time
masturbate
waste 33 size 29. what do we have in
common you get smaller as you go down
okay
foreign
Drive the weather with a word or phrase
that would also describe your wife wet
wet
during what months of pregnancy does a
woman begin to look pregnant September
you know John yesterday doesn't she have
pretty nipples uh pretty dimples
foreign
part of the body mentioned in many love
songs
I'm gonna go for the breasts
a yellow fruit orange name an animal
with three letters in its name
frog
name an animal with three letters in its
name alligator
you don't use uh you don't use narcotics
do you bomb
no but I mean I thought frog was bad I
thought frog was a disastrous answer
until you came up with alligator you
give me the name of a planet the Sun
the sun's a planet to planet we don't go
to the Stars I was going to say it's a
plan I bet you other people believe on
my side
but you're saying I bet you it's a
planet we know it's not effective right
okay 100 people to name something that
comes in sevens
catalog fingers
that's 100 people to name a game you
could play in the bath
Annette
scuba diving
the nicknames cheese mongers Cherry
Pickers Bob's own the emperor's chamber
maids and the Immortals are or have been
used for which groups of men
you miss bright homosexuals
give me a slang name for policemen
dick
okay
maybe see what he said
this term for a long-handled gardening
tool can also mean an immoral pleasure
Seeker okay what's a hoe no whoa
whoa
whoa
they teach you that in school in Utah
huh L what's a rake a rake is right
something made of wool
sheep
what a girl should know about a man
before she marries him
just got it Lynn what would you what
would you say his name he's what name
his name
name something made of leather
[Applause]
yes sir a purse
you're going to be slightly embarrassed
when I finish this question a purse
[Music]
Cowboy uses
name something you eat frozen
sorry cat
show me cat
name a country
a man with a mustache should visit to
meet a woman with the Mustang
France yeah yeah Paris
we asked 100 people to name a place
where you wouldn't expect to meet a nun
Janet a brothel
most of the electricity in our home
flows from the blank to the what from
the plug to the vibrator
name something you feel before you buy
it
excited
what country will your husband say the
last foreign car he wrote in was
manufactured Fran the United States
that's not a foreign country
um
Texas
name something that a person with long
legs might not be able to fit into
I'm going to go with long pants
all right
[Music]
roses are red violets are blue on our
wedding night my husband what we went to
bed
what will your husband say is his
favorite thing to squeeze in the
supermarket Jane I say is meat his meat
something a burglar would not want to
see when he breaks into a house
[Applause]
I don't want to see that either buddy
what country has the highest ratio of
doctors to population
the country with the most Jews
I guess
I would say Israel
you have a doctor in every family it's a
cousin could be an uncle okay
buddy buddy ought to know I'll agree you
agree with that
it's Israel
[Applause]
a vegetable you marinate
grapes
we surveyed 100 people in an antonym a
way of toasting someone
Michelle over a fire
I'll tell you what
if you jump there I'll give you the
money myself
[Applause]
over a fire
oh no
give me a boy's name that starts with
the letter h
Jose
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
name something you might buy that could
turn out to be phony
yeah a horse
they dreaded phony horse
[Music]
Skagen Miners And Hoes no
time starts now
a group of pill pushers
this is Wheel of Fortune yo if it were
up to me I'd never blank again
cheat cheat
[Applause]
you could have said are you an idiot a
man falls out of your boat and into the
water you should yell Man Overboard now
what should you yell if a woman falls
overboard Full Speed Ahead
foreign
something besides soap and a towel that
people take with them to the bath
a duck
something people take with him to the
bath besides sober Tao
ISE up
we asked 100 people to name a non-living
object which has feet
Caroline
plant a plant is a non-living object
something people take with them to the
beach
turkey the
first thing you buy in a supermarket uh
turkey
food often stuffed turkey